[Music]
okay I was probably 12 my older brother
was 16 and Sol trains on we're watching
all these beautiful people coming down
the Sol train line and they're dancing
and it's beautiful and I was probably
sitting there like
[Applause]
this no matter what your thing was it
was on Soul Train no matter what you
liked Soul Train had it at the best and
most beautiful and most fashionable and
most stylish and being able to move and
dance and that being so attractive and
moving and freeing and
[Music]
liberating Soul Train got Society to see
black people as they really are these
people just being their beautiful
authentic no ho bars this is what I am
and this is what I do it gave a voice to
a generation and then it gave a voice to
a generation after that and then it give
a voice to a generation after that and I
love nothing better than for soul train
to be a historical lesson and that's why
it's an important
[Music]
work I'm a lead partner and a lead
producer on the show every step of my
career I've worked on the creative side
and the business side and what I like to
do is put big huge things together that
are complex and that have lots of
different dimensions and then something
really important comes out on the other
end this is the first time in Broadway
history that at the creative core of a
musical there will be three black women
on it writer director and choreographer
and all of a sudden we have this music
and this writing and this choreography
and the direction and the dancers and
the actors and the lighting and the
staging is crazy and all of a sudden
this magic happens and that is really
really
[Music]
special one of the things that me and my
part Partners feel is it's our
responsibility to get the story out to
the world and we can't do that if it's
not commercially viable we can't so we
have to make a great Broadway show
period Soul training was a universal
brand and what we need to do is tell
that story to the universe and Make It
Last Forever the way we change the
industry whether it's this industry or
film or the broader entertainment
industry is by winning and being
successful and we feel that
responsibility and we're here for it all
day long bring
it
our investor pool if we stopped right
now would be one of the most diverse
investor pools in the history of
Broadway the black community has turned
out to support this show not only in
terms of buying tickets but in terms of
writing checks and that's important you
got to support works you got to support
works that matter and I'm humbled by
that I'm not humbled by that for me I'm
humbled by that by my community turned
out to support this thing that I thought
was important my partners thought was
important that we put this unbelievable
team around and people rallied and that
is
humbling there's the importance of the
show the importance of the story the
importance of diversifying the community
and the importance of changing the
industry and you get very few times in
life when you can have something that
can have that broad of an impact and to
be able to be one of the stewards of
that is a gift and that's how we see it
it is a responsibility it is important
but damn it's a gift to be able to have
that and try and make something
work my name is Richard gay and I am the
founder and the CEO of a company called
five pack
[Music]
entertainment